chancellor sebastian race
to be in paris today after
the terrorist attack which mourned
cheating last week and to repeat here
our full solidarity with all the
austrian people we were
french and french struck in the heart
by terrorism  islamist and i know
the emotion the mourning that has struck
you also thanks chancellor
angela merkel prime
minister marc croteau and the presidents
of the european council and the
european commission charles michel and ursula von
der leyen with whom we have just met
maintain a
videoconference in a little over an
hour in order to build together the
common reaction to these terrorist attacks
marked on the one hand by European solidarity
after the attacks in Paris
conflent nice and come but also
by a clear conscience  that the threat of
terrorism and violent extremism
weighs on all European countries
all our capitals all who are  my people
gathered here have been affected and terrorism
from paris to brussels to
berlin vienna utrecht london madrid
barcelona copenhagen stockholm nice are
coming now and so many more is
a european reality that we
need to respond to
that is why we need  of a
coordinated and rapid joint response
, that is what we have agreed today,
methodical work will follow in
the coming weeks and a first
meeting with all of our
colleagues during the December board meeting.
intergovernmental work
to improve security coordination of
the work of our services with
each other to fight
terrorism in order to organize ourselves better
also in order to fight against all forms
of radicalization in our societies in
this regard I salute and all the work
that has  been done by the netherlands for
several years which for us is very
inspiring the work also done
by austria for pl  For several years, no,
we have spoken at length and which will be
the subject of French initiatives in the
coming weeks.
The priority is the
full and rigorous implementation of the arsenal of
measures that Europe adopted after
the 2015 attacks.  and we
find ourselves today three days before
the 5th anniversary of the attacks in
paris and precisely before this is the moment
when we will have to gather at the end
of the week to commemorate the memory
also of the attacks which have mourned
our capital and that  is at the end of these
attacks which hit france in
2015 that we were able to accelerate and
put in place an important set of
measures what we need to do is
go to the end of the implementation of
this one  the development of
common databases cooperation between our
police forces our exchanges of information the
strengthening of our penal system
the completion of the so-called pnr system
but it is also essential that this
d  ispositif is therefore so
implemented with databases that are
quickly linked together because
any security breach at
the external border or in one of
the member states is a security risk
for all the member states and
therefore  our concentration on the
finalization of the implementation
of all of these
information system measures such as
legal mechanisms is essential
and we will take stock in December on
this subject the second axis that we have
mentioned is the fight  with
determination against
terrorist propaganda and hate speech on the
internet the
internet is a space of freedom our
social networks too
but this freedom only exists if there is
security and if it is not the
refuge of those who  flout our values
k to indoctrinate with deadl
ideology that
s why the regulation on the remov
l of terrorist content from
he internet within one hour
must absolutely be
adopted in the coming weeks this
essential is the result of
work that we had initiated here
at the time with theresa may in the summer of 2010
is and which must find in the
coming weeks  this completion
is also why we
strongly support the commission's desire to
propose new
legislation at the beginning of December to combat the
dissemination of hate speech
the dds directive is an
essential step which we have also talked about
at length finally
and i have  had the opportunity to say it
last week at the perthus in france
we must work on an overhaul of
the schengen space
it is essential we must in no way
confuse the fight against illegal immigration
and terrorism
but we must look  lucidly
the links which exist between these two
phenomena the attack of nice
unfortunately is also
the illustration of it the space of free
movement schengen is one of the
principal acqui  s of European construction
,
but it rested in return for the
promise of free movement without
internal borders on a promise
to protect and secure our
external borders, this second
promise was not sufficiently kept
and the public opinions of the states
confronted with the  terrorist threat
we will be able to accept the
maintenance of our borders open for a long time
if we do not reform
the schengen area in depth
we saw it in the spring in the
context of the pandemic we are seeing it
today with regard to
terrorism
we must therefore reform  the
schengen area so that it is also a
security area, which implies strengthening
the security of the external borders
of the european union of clothing
improving the mechanisms for evaluating the
operation of schengen, including by
sanctioning those who do not respect
their obligations to renew the
governance of this space which does
not currently  subject to
regular political monitoring encompassing all
the policies concerned, whether it be
borders, asylum, migration,
internal security, I am in favor of
this as soon as we can put
in place a real council of
internal security we will have
the opportunity in the next few days to
make the proposal to the other states
here present
reform project and to share it
with all the notes of our colleagues in order
to be able to move forward in this matter to
reform schengen is to allow
freedom  in safety these are the few
areas on which I wanted to return
by thanking again
Chancellor Scheer Sébastien for being
in Paris today but all our
colleagues for having agreed to
react very quickly to organize the response
and an essential European response
that is  is what we have just experienced on
sebastien de monsieur le chancellor the
pressure top 10 but as long as the makrout
group has named david to the miss  ion
terrible shock let's throw to the table that his
solidarity
in france
east critics and fans of final
fight for the rain internet we
next terrorism say it's a
strict form and in admin had
stepfather in nantes again
chalon thank you very much but i  am
chancellor angela merkel is
coming and paris viii
is what they won't offer therefore in
right internet the artist she weaves
between the parliaments confidences that
compromised fine way and bruce aust
rockliffe of maggots of these materials
portuguese minister n  have not taken shape
a 206 social bond in france
[Music]
shot at griffin interpreted the roles
of 6 apr thank you very much at English I
'm going to give the floor now we
're prime minister mark rutte them
your leaflets  or 5 you go of photos in show
and sainte foy sillery this agreement with a
group of origin a conflict no except
then yes to the fact of ghana
the madness as the export continues to free
cries or  i thank you very much i notice i
am going to give the floor now
president of the european council has
taken charge michel the
european union is democracy
these are the values of funda
ental freedoms and this battle that we ar
waging together against terro
ism is  is a battle to preserve our
fundamental values
mobilized to work in order
to strengthen security and t
is is what we are going with the h
ads of state of government with the m
nisters and the european commission to conti
ue to progress to ensur
that  there is more security and
to reduce this
terrorist threat so in recent years a
lot of things have been initiated a
lot of things have been
implemented but it is extremely important
to observe how we can
still improve things and what  will be
the meaning of the meeting at the level of the
muscles of the interior which will be held this
Friday will be the occasion to take
stock of  the state of progress the state
of implementation of what has been decided
sometimes for several years it
will also be an opportunity to see how we can
speed up specified improve a certain
number of processes and then I made a
commitment we will have to  again in
December at the level of Heads of State
and Government the opportunity to take stock again
to ensure that we are giving
the political impetus and
orientations so that progress is
made
I put forward a few points which
seem to me  important
on the one hand as others have said
before me to roll back the plush of
terrorism fiercely fight these
messages of hatred
this apology for violence and keys
in particular in the internet space it is
the meaning of a work which
started some time ago and we hope
that we will be able to take formal decisions
to succeed in very
quickly removing terrorist content
from internet spaces
and then another point that  close to my
heart because I know that in
many European countries it is a real
subject how can we encourage the
training of imams in europe how
can we ensure that art is drawn with
respect, of course, for the freedom of
awareness freedom of religion which
is an extremely extremely
important weight in europe how can we
guarantee that these fundamental values
not possible to accommodate that
t is firmly guaranteed firml
to protect and finally there is anoth
r element that holds us  at heart
it is the need to conduct international dialogue
it has been said europe guarantees
freedom of
conscience europe guarantees the freedom for everyone
to believe or not to believe
and therefore europe also wants to be
involved in  international dialogue
so as not to fall into the trap of those
who try to exploit those
who try to feed hatred to
feed separation and that is the meaning
of diplomatic activity  intense eu
that we will continue to carry out with
peaks outside europe to explain
what our values are to explain who i
our determination to act again
t terrorism to protect freed
ms to protect democracy thank
you dear in charge finally give the floor
to  the president
the european commission the president
ursula von der leyen chair my
column in this her assistants have
made initiatives at the end of
this woman's life said mr
let's concentrate vast and cabaye european commission in gaza
and the magnificent women and album baby
nyn's to maintain and  active part
in prevention
once the quays of saône claudio
extremism respectively
[Music
] integration inclusion now needs
benchmark phase where we will go do an
easy cop at 7 p.m. bring it back strelok approach
to yours china growth internet
legal platforms on line in haiti  get
far cry and the triggers
[Music]
it's a phone platform said
dan dah followed  hours at the docks
own role but who is not
via the information chain bridge
estimate fabrice black jersey 6% to the
passenger against his small size full
contact
thank you very much at for that we
will pass now in question
we will take four  questions
the first is for the german press
in berlin
pretty voice
[Music]
they tell me but what is being gay
president I allowed myself to start
since here in your house you are
probably the last defenders  of this
European fundamental right
the open borders and there suddenly we
have the impression that you have
changed your conviction a little after following the
terrorist attack in Nice
please nickname please that you
have not  changed conviction how
do you want so here are precisely
your ideas on the strengthening of
controls
thank you very much
just a word to reassure you I believe
in European cooperation
resolutely  t and moreover we have
shown it by being very attached during
this pandemic, keeping our borders
open and having
strong European coordination and I believe very
deeply indeed in this right and
our common functioning I
simply think that in the face of the threats that
are ours today this right is only
tenable and this freedom is
only tenable if we better protect
our common external borders
what I have tried to recall is therefore
this discussion we have had for
five years now at the level  European
on the great migrations we have it
since the great migrations and the
first migratory shock first of
marennes de precisely of the
Mediterranean Sea and
which first affected Italy then the
great wave of migration which arrived
linked to the conflict  skiing nothing and we
have not succeeded in completing this
reform what we want to do
is complete a reform in
terms of migration which allows us  you to
rearticulate the couple responsibility
solidarity which allows us to
keep our borders open between us
but by better protecting our
external borders today we
have shortcomings on this point and
particularly I think is one of the
subjects of which  we will have to seize
collectively we are witnessing in all
our countries a diversion of what the
right of asylum is the right of asylum is made
for peace fighters
raises those who take a risk for
their political choices in their country  and
today we see
more and more people arriving who apply for the
right of asylum in europe and who come
from countries which are not at war to
which we give hundreds of
thousands of visas each year and therefore
there is a  diversion which is used
by traffickers by
clearly identified networks and therefore our
desire is to better build our
concerted common response to better
protect our fr  common areas of
better coping with these
contemporary phenomena to better keep our
borders open between us so I
can reassure you about the fundamentals which
remain the same as far as I am concerned,
but the pragmatism which must be
ours
given the threats and realities to
which  we face
conditional that made based on a
perfect cooperation tackle
third question by the dutch press
rtl please
according to
feng who wants evidence
there and you hear us
fritz schiesser from schengen
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen an i
would like to come back to the idea of tightening the r
ception conditions, particularly for a
ylum, can you all t
ll us if you share this point of view and what
ould be the ways of possibly reducing and tight
ning these conditions and t
en, moreover, I  allow me
to add another aspect of another
battle which concerns all Europeans
did you talk about the man  to make it impossible to make a
vaccine accessible to all
Europeans
or perhaps we were talking about
travel to distribute it by making it
compulsory for travel, which we
could, what some
already consider a way of pushing people to
get vaccinated
thank you thank you very much on the first
point that things are clear we
have a pact which was proposed by the
commission and which is an
extremely important working basis
we wish to be able to complete the
proposed measures with measures on our
common border but also the
governance of the  schengen area
as moreover the chancellor the
chancellor is the prime minister or
you have also reminded you of this in each of
their answers and it is not a question of
reducing the right of asylum would have been decided
as you said  but it is
very clearly a question of having it
fully applied and of fighting against the voices
of hijacking it and of better
protecting the external borders
comm  ones which are ours and which have
been sorely tested in recent
years but it's been I think that
now we are obliged
to do because it's been I said it
five years that we debate it with
we saw it
a l  impossibility of going to the end
on the one hand of
intra-European solidarity on this subject
once women and men have arrived on
common ground and successive failures in
our ability to overhaul our
common regulations, therefore our
will is truly  now to
strengthen things is to do so by
also taking as a base schengen which
must be a space of responsibility
and solidarity which means that if some
are not also ready to carry the
rules but we will draw all the
consequences on the health subject
we did not mention it in the
videoconference that we had
together but there is a European Council
which is scheduled for next week and
which will be dedicated to this subject I remind  thank you
again to the rotating presidency and the
permanent presidency of the council
of europe and for having organized
these visions on a regular basis between us,
the european commission is also carrying out
extremely rigorous work on the
coordination of common
consultation orders and in particular
on  organization of all our efforts on
the vaccine strategy
so we will have the opportunity to talk about it
next week we were able to
talk about it with the Chancellor
yesterday and we talked about it this afternoon with
the Chancellor is therefore  of
course we have
very close coordination to both pursue all
the prospectuses sought to organize
production and distribution in our territories
and to have European cooperation
in this area
very well thank you all thank you
very much thank you for your attention and
thank you to our  colleagues from berlin there
and brussels for their cooperation and
their work
thank you all thank you my  Ladies Gentlemen
[Music]